[Musica]
una volta c'erano le chiacchiere da bar
quelle che rimanevano bene o male nel
circondario dove la gente abitava però
da qualche anno queste sono state in
qualche modo trasmesse via diretta
streaming reperibili 24 ore su 24 7
giorni su 7 365 giorni all'anno
purtroppo devo dire una cosa non c'è
quella giornata libera negli anni di
sestili quindi purtroppo anche quel
giorno circolano ci troviamo in una
situazione in cui chiunque può dire la
propria attraverso il web
la classica casalinga di voghera di cui
non sappiamo mai l'identità è diventata
famosa ma diventata famosa anche quella
di chip e dischi su una piccola frazione
di un comune friulano
improvvisamente un post facebook può
diventare una notizia nazionale o
addirittura internazionale con sfondi
già politici c'era il caso di un soldato
russo alexander che purtroppo è morto in
siria perché vi parli questa notizia
perché era circolata ovunque la notizia
e la sua morte giudicata eroica perché
era circolata una trascrizione delle sue
ultime parole con il suo comandante in
cui salutava la famiglia e incitava i
suoi colleghi suoi compagni di lotta per
essere bombardato nel punto in cui si
trovava
perché circondato dall isis un gesto
eroico una trascrizione che sembrava
tratta da un film americano
strano per un russo la cosa ancora più
strana è che ne parlavano tutti inglesi
italiani ma non ancora i russi sono
arrivati dopo e che mi ha fatto un po
pensare come mai una notizia che doveva
riguardare la glorificazione
dell'esercito russo non veniva diciamo
discussa dagli stessi russi sono rinati
dopo facendo una ricerca inversa del
testo che era circolato ho scoperto che
veniva diffuso attraverso blog commenti
in qualche social fino a quando è
arrivata la fonte primaria un post
facebook
pubblicato dell'utente del bangladesh
giusto poco dopo il decesso la notizia
del decesso di questo ragazzo io mi
domando come possa questo utente del
bangladesh essere entrato in possesso di
una trascrizione dell'esercito russo in
tempi così stretti
era una fantasia tanto che però è
diventata notizia internazionale i russi
poi l'hanno cavalcata l'hanno diffusa
anche sui loro canali televisivi
però almeno hai avuto la decenza di
scrivere nei loro schermi trascrizione
non verificata ecco a me non ho avuto
una parvenza di onestà i media sono
manipolabili
abbiamo visto adesso l'esempio ma in
realtà lo sono gli esseri umani
noi siamo continuamente coinvolti
emotivamente in diversi racconti
attraverso diverse storie ci sono le
emozioni positive come questo soldato
che in qualche modo dicono ecco un eroe
che lotta contro il male ma poi c'è
anche le altre emozione quella dell'odio
quella della rabbia verso un qualcosa
che non sopportiamo una mattina un
ragazzo di collecchio vicino a parma si
era svegliato con decine di messaggi
social di odio minacce
il tutto perché qualcuno aveva creato un
account facebook che aveva mandato un
messaggio preciso ad alcune persone per
dire segnalate questo ragazzo a facebook
perché pedofilo
a parte che non segnali un pedofilo a
facebook o meno segnali e le autorità
però attraverso quel singolo messaggio e
la casa è stato completamente bombardato
gli insulti non solo perché dal web se
passate la realtà lui aveva un bar il
suo varo è stato banalizzato la sua
macchina completamente vandalizzata
minacce di morte gente che girano per
strada allestire una familiari che si
domandavano ma cosa è successo dopo la
denuncia la polizia
la verifica che lui non si trattava
appunto di un pedofilo
c'è stata una necessità di una contro
narrazione perché di fronte a questa
ondata incredibile passato su gli
strozza come facebook e altri c'è stato
bisogno di appunto un racconto
per dire era una bufala e far tornare in
qualche modo alla normalità una vita
normale a questo ragazzo
lui comunque ha perso il bar ha dovuto
ricominciare da capo
però se ci pensate è bastato un singolo
messaggio facebook ci troviamo appunto
in una questione di emozioni nell'ultimo
periodo soprattutto quello pandemico c'è
stata la paura c'è stata anche la
speranza speranza misto rabbia
soprattutto quando di fronte una
situazione così incerta qualcuno
viaggiando in giro per il mondo
attraverso questo strumento il cellulare
ha pensato di fare dei video per dire io
mi trovo in giappone hanno scoperto una
medicina miracolosa contro la corrida
oppure un altro che era in russia e
anche lui ho scoperto che qua utilizzano
questo prodotto farmaceutico che non vi
vogliono raccontare che non vi vogliono
vendere peccato che tutte queste cure
come anche quella che si parlava della
vitamina c e altre teorie non sono state
provate a di sanzionando non abbiamo
ancora una cura però affascinante come
c'era questo sentimento di trovare una
soluzione allo stesso tempo di rabbia
nei confronti delle istituzioni che non
volevano curare e vedetevi conto che
erano messaggi che capitano spesso non
solamente attraverso questi video in cui
c'è questo principio di autorevolezza
verso l'amico che magari sarà laureato
all'università dei social che ha più
credibilità di una rivista scientifica
blasonata però cosa succede quando a
parlare è un vero medico e questo vi
propone una cura per esempio contro il
cancro una cura che costa poco come
quella del bicarbonato tempo fa eravamo
agli albori di internet un medico
attraverso anche pagine sui siti e su
forum di discussione si parlava appunto
di questa cura contro il cancro col
bicarbonato alla fine cosa costa in
gioco il mercato costa poco però poi
alla fine tutti i fidi cerchi di
ottenere una speranza nell'uscire da un
male incurabile e ti affidi a lui come
successo con una famiglia si sono
affidati si son fatti portare
figlio in albania e con questa
inesistente cura l'hanno ucciso
il medico è stato poi condannato è stato
ovviamente radiato dall'ordine
però se ci pensate tutta questa cosa
nasce sulla emozione sulla ricerca di
una speranza e su quello che veniva
raccontato sui social
ricordo che nel 2014 mi dicevano che io
mi occupavo di sciocchezze di persone
che in qualche modo non erano capaci di
comprendere facilmente manipolabili e
problema che tutto questo fenomeno
veniva un po sottovalutato anche persone
intelligenti laureate persone di spicco
che potevano credere anche a quel
messaggio mandato via messenger via
whatsapp con il meme di una persona con
scritto questa è la figlia dei tale
italy politico taldeitali che guadagna
10.000 20.000 30.000 euro al mese pagata
dallo stato
scandalo peccato che non si vedevano
conto che quella persona ritratta in
quell'immagine era la cantante rihanna
ma a questo punto del 12 ma chi non
conosce rihanna
il problema è proprio questo che non
tutti possiamo conoscere tutto e tutti
c'è chi non conosce rihanna c'è chi non
conosce altre persone
ed è questo che porta le persone a
credere ai principi di autorevolezza e
l'autorevolezza verso quella persona che
vi ha condiviso quel messaggio 15
possono cascare tutti in fin dei conti
uno può dire vabbè ma se una massa di
creduloni che creda tutto per esempio ci
sono di quelli che credendo alle più
disparate teorie di complotto e
quant'altro per esempio quella dei qua
non
poi sono finiti un giorno per strada
hanno deciso di salutare il tempio della
democrazia americana
l'abbiamo visto tutti nelle arti gene e
nelle televisioni
eppure ci siamo soffermati tanto su quel
personaggio che in pieno inverno a petto
nudo o vestito con un copricapo da
sciamano una cosa molto folkloristica
ci siamo concentrati su di lui ma non
c'era solamente lui c'erano anche
persone importanti persone di spicco
della comunità americana ma addirittura
dei politici che si sono candidati sono
finiti nel parlamento americano e
credono alla tele di qua non
qui non serve solamente pensare che ci
sia uno sciocco dietro ci può essere una
persona di cui forse non ti aspetteresti
mai che possa credere a certe cose
torniamo all'età della pietra in verità
l'età della pietra la vediamo anche sui
social quotidianamente quindi non c'è
neanche il bisogno di fare un passo
indietro e lasciare da parte la
tecnologia la tecnologia ci ha permesso
di andare avanti di proseguire insomma
la nostra aumentare la nostra capacità
culturale e sociale
però non dobbiamo dimenticarci che i
mezzi sono creati dall essere umano è
l'essere umano non è perfetto e il
problema proprio è questo che noi magari
sopra valutiamo la tecnologia e
sottovalutiamo l'uomo l'uomo può fare
tantissime cose può fare benissimo
errori
il problema non è facebook twitter
youtube
il problema è come li utilizziamo come e
dobbiamo anche prendere una volta per
tutte perché non possiamo demonizzare un
mezzo che di fatto ci sta portando a
degli aspetti positivi se siamo qui
appunto per la nostra tecnologia se
siamo qui è perché insomma ce l'ha
permesso l'evoluzione della nostra
cultura
la censura potrebbe essere una soluzione
zittire queste realtà assurde
assolutamente no rendiamoci conto che
noi dobbiamo imparare dagli errori
da questo punto di vista un po il fact
checking lo considero come una sorta di
vaccino contro informa la
disinformazione perché in qualche modo
ci permette di individuare quelle
falsità di individuare con le truffe qui
ciarlatani affinché in un futuro stiamo
molto più attenti un po come appunto
funziona col vaccino ci allena il
sistema immunitario per difenderci dalla
malattia
tuttavia non è neanche una soluzione
definitiva il fact checking
assolutamente no ci sono tante cose che
si possono fare
ci sono tante attività che possiamo
portare avanti per rendere il web
migliore ma non riusciremo mai e poi mai
a rendere un web completamente pulito da
quello che sono i creduloni i violenti i
truffatori come del resto la realtà del
nostro mondo non avremmo mai un mondo
privo di qualcuno di cattivo di qualcuno
che voglia farci del male anche se un po
spero che questa mia ultima in questo
mio ultimo pensiero
lui sa che prima o poi a sbuffa l'arma